this session we have Juan Ki Perdomo and
then later on more it's hard giving
talks so the first talk is difficult
lessons on social prediction from
Wisconsin Public Schools thanks
um great thank you so much Nika so
um so today I'll be talking about some
joint work with uh talani Britton Moritz
heart and ready Habibi
um on difficult lessons on social
prediction from Wisconsin public schools
and I want to start out by thanking Carl
Frederick and Justin Meyer at the
Wisconsin Department of Public
Instruction without them we wouldn't
have been able to do this project
so the topic for today's talk is we're
going to be evaluating individual risk
predictors that are used in U.S public
education
particularly when you talk about early
warning systems and the question we're
going to try to answer is that does this
really popular class of risk predictors
improve educational outcomes and my
educational outcomes I made High School
graduation rates in U.S Public Schools
great so early Warning Systems the first
pilot started around 2007
and they very quickly boomed so
according to a survey by the U.S federal
department of education over half of U.S
public schools had implemented some
version of an early warning system by
2015.
and the main question these early
Warning Systems try to answer is will a
particular student graduate on time from
high school so they use features from
students in middle school and they make
a prediction as to whether the student
will graduate from high school in four
years so like within the standard
timeline
right
and the thesis Behind These early
Warning Systems is that they're meant to
improve graduation rates so I've kind of
highlighted the main pipeline here in
three stages so the first step behind
early Warning Systems is early
identification step so typically they
make predictions on the population of
students sometime around 8th grade or
like before high school and the main
output of the system at this point is
like a set of high risk Flags like these
are the students we think are unlikely
to graduate from high school on time and
these flags are used by data teams and
counselors within schools to Target
interventions to students that they
believe need help
with the idea of increasing the number
of students that graduate on time from
high school
so the question we're going to try to
answer today is this thesis really true
like just what extent does this idea
really map on to reality
great
so in particular if you're looking at
the Wisconsin dues program so Dropout
early warning system and this is a early
warning system that was implemented by
the Department of Public Instruction
starting in 2012 and it's used Statewide
so it makes predictions on every single
student in Wisconsin Public Schools
particularly from fifth to 8th grade so
we're talking over 200 000 students each
year
um the system it has two main outputs so
the first one is a dues label so this is
like a holistic evaluation of How likely
does the DPI think that a particular
student will graduate from high school
on time so
um and this is like according to the
action guide they published this is like
the main piece of actionable information
that the system provides so low being
that we don't there's a low risk of this
student dropping out and a higher risk
being that we really think the student
should be intervened on immediately
um in addition to the dues label they
output a score which is really just like
a probability of graduation and these
two quantities are related as we'll
literally see in the talk
um in terms of implementation they use
things like random forests classical
like kind of machine learning methods
for tabular data and the models
themselves use a pretty rich set of
features so they really do a good job of
like collecting a lot of data around
students that really describe both
students and their communities so in
particular uh I'll try to categorize
this like a large set of features into
two broad classes the first one is like
individual features these are quantities
that describe individual students like
what was my test score on the
standardized exam how many days was I in
school even things like what is my
gender what is my race
and then there's things about students
communities like what fraction of my
school is non-white what fraction of my
school qualifies for a free reduced
lunch so these are not so much things
about me as a student but really
describing the people around me
so something to keep in mind as we go
along
so kind of going back to this thesis
early warning systems are really about
targeting I'm glad to go after Emily
because this is at a high level
something very similar that to what's
happening in the IRS problem so
targeting is you know resources are
scarce Public Schools we can't intervene
on every student right so we're faced
with this difficult problem of trying to
understand which students need the most
help right so we're going to use
prediction to try to answer this
question who needs the most help
so as computer scientists we can think
about these as just sorting algorithms
right we take as input a population of
students in public schools and we output
A ranked list of these students where
the ranking is according to this Dropout
risk so here higher numbers means you're
more likely to graduate from school on
time and the Dropout risk serves as like
concrete proxy for an otherwise
subjective notion of you know how much
do you need an intervention
go ahead
so given this analogy that early warning
systems are really just sorting
algorithms
um this is kind of like the evaluation
framework that we're going to use so an
effective early warning system should do
two things first it should prioritize
students accurately right students who
are in higher need of an intervention
are more likely to drop out should
appear at the front of this list whereas
students who are generally doing well
should appear further towards the back
and moreover these predictions you know
they're made with the very explicit
intent of changing outcomes
um so the prediction that a student is
high risk should hopefully be a
self-negating prophecy they should
change outcomes they should be
performative
right so if I predict that a particular
student is at high risk versus I predict
that a particular student is at low risk
this should hopefully change the
likelihood that they graduate from high
school on time
any questions so far do you just have
one Central warning system for the state
or is it just more like each school's
half they have their own um like model
separately great yeah so uh early
morning systems across the U.S vary in
implementation the one I'm talking about
today is implemented the state level so
the State Department of Education
generates predictions that are sent out
to every school
are trained on include whether students
are intervened on
no
so relatedly how do you measure this
is
so they're pretty broad there are a lot
of like demographic information like
gender race uh things about us like
income like does the student qualify for
free reduced lunch there's academic
performance whether it should have been
subject to disciplinary history
um and a lot of things about students
communities like what fraction of school
is not and what what's the
um how many school students in the
school qualify for services things like
that can you say quickly again what year
this prediction is based on so the
system started in 2012 and it's been
used up until now the system makes
predictions in fifth sixth seventh and
8th today I'll be talking about mostly
the eighth grade model so I guess yes
good question the kind of the typical
way this prediction is used is to triage
students as they come into High School
it's like when students change School
enter ninth grade data teams or
counselors look at the predictions try
to understand which students should be
painting
great so jumping straight into the
findings we find that these Deuce
predictions are actually very highly
accurate so like they provide a very
good signal regarding which students
will graduate from high school on time
and which ones won't
unfortunately the system does not
improve outcomes all right so there's no
sense in which or we find no evidence
that this high level of predictive
accuracy is translated into higher
graduation rates in Wisconsin
and we hold an explanation that's based
on the role of environmental factors in
this system and I'll get into more
detail exactly what I mean here
great so starting with the accuracy dues
is quite good at prediction
so I mentioned there were two main
outputs right the label and then the
score so look at those separately
so starting with the score amongst the
group of students over the last 10 years
that were predicted to be at low risk of
graduating of dropping out from school
97 of these students graduated and
amongst the students that were predicted
to be at high risk only 70 of those
graduated
moderate risk students it's a relatively
smaller bucket only like six percent of
students are assigned to this bucket but
it lies somewhere in between and these
gaps are pretty significant relative to
the 90 graduation rate uh in Wisconsin
Public Schools as a whole so for context
90 actually quite high
for our U.S schools for U.S states
um moreover we can look at the score
um so I'm here I'm plotting the
calibration curve for the predicted
probability so on the x-axis this is the
predicted probability of graduation and
then I'm bucketing students by their
predicted probability and looking at for
a particular bucket what fraction of
those students graduated
so we see that as a whole the score is
miscalibrated right it should really lie
on this like blue dotted line
but this miscalibration is relatively
mild right because we don't really care
about what's the real number we only
care about these numbers in a relative
sense so like if I am more likely to
drop out of school then my number should
be lower than for a student who's less
likely to drop out of school so as long
as this like purple curve is like a line
with a positive slope the score is good
yeah this is after intervention right uh
hold on to that yeah
um good so from this sense like going
back to the Sorting algorithm analogy
like the list that we're outputting is
actually pretty well ranked right like
really students who do need more
interventions appear at the beginning of
the list
I'm sorry
the graduation rate was in the bucket
varies significantly between well I
guess relative to the average graduation
rates like these numbers really do mean
positively different things yes so I
think they're doing better than than
melted it's better than addiction it
doesn't say you're anywhere close to the
base optimality yeah okay yeah
um but you know it's not it's a
non-trivial signal of whether someone's
going to drop off yeah good uh
good so but ultimately these predictions
are ineffective so if I know evidence
that these high risk predictions lead to
effective interventions and here I'm
trying to answer a counter factual
question right like what is the outcome
of a particular student if I predict
them to be at high risk versus at low
risk and I'm doing this based off
observational data so I better have some
sort of experiment happening here
we need to say the same thing but
uh why is it not calibrated
so yeah I don't think the briefs are
effective I'll try to prove that to you
now
um
so we can leverage a national a natural
experiment so particularly like the do's
label is determined by thresholding a
continuous score right so we predict
this probability of graduation and if it
lies above a arbitrary threshold by set
by the department of students assigned
to the high risk bucket versus if it's
below
um you get put into a moderate wrist
bucket so you can try to estimate this
treatment effect of what is the effect
of assigning people different
predictions via regression discontinuity
design and this leverages the idea that
like if you look at students whose
predicted probabilities lies very close
to this threshold you essentially have
like a randomized experiment here
okay
so we find that we ran this rdd and then
we find that this treatment effect of
predicting changing the prediction for
moderate to high risk changes stop
students graduation likelihood of
graduation by less than five percent
but the resulting confidence interval
covers zero so you can't reject the
hypothesis that this prediction has Zero
Effect
I could imagine like maybe
it works better on some popular
these predictions could have very
different effects on different
populations fortunately we can't answer
the question for the very very bottom
students because we don't have any kind
of randomization there
um
great and then you can also look at this
analogous comparison of trying to
predict like what's the treatment effect
of changing someone's label from low to
moderate risk and there you get an even
smaller effect so less than less than
three percent
good
so what we find is going back yeah well
um do you know that the the borderline
by word treated because maybe you know
within school they don't even have
budgeting
on the border between yeah so we don't
have
um
weather intervention is performed is not
something we can track on the data right
but what we can say is that the
intervention like assigning a high-risk
label does not lead to an effective
intervention right so it could be the
case that an intervention was performed
that it had Zero Effect
um yeah uh could this year
very few people are assigned moderate
label I'd say like confidence intervals
around what happens for people assigned
moderate or just always going to be huge
um yes they could be huge so this is
like it was like a testosterical power
right like we don't have like a tiny
confidence interval sure it could be the
case that the effect is non-zero but
it's definitely not a huge number and
that's something we can do that is the
intervention that are required on
students that are unable as moderate
risk similar to the ones as for high
risk because you're saying like the
checking on the on the margin between
low and moderate
so would you expect that the same amount
of attention would be given to moderate
students as high students
like it's the strength of the
intervention the same for high risk and
moderate risk students sorry they like
all purple kind of experience
yeah
um
yes I think that they would be
comparable interventions but you're
intervening on different students right
so like uh if for example we interviewed
on a student who's probably at
graduation absent intervention is like
99 this intervention you know you're
you're up around being the treatment
effect of this intervention okay all
right so you would expect expect to see
different effect sizes uh in the
moderate to high risk comparison versus
low to moderate because these students
look very different
I think it's what's the power of uh so
you said you don't you don't the effect
is significant right but how significant
and effective the negotiation rates
around the the cutoff they're around 90
how something one in ten let's say you
know there's one project is 10 how big
an effect would you have been able to
detect
uh
um
let's say
so his interval width is 14. so
over there
[Music]
and then this time maybe you can move on
so the idea is that uh going back to the
Sorting algorithm technology it doesn't
matter where we put students at the
front of the list or on the back of the
list seems like their graduation the
likelihood of graduation is the same all
right so artificially cheating someone's
place in the list has not changed their
outcomes
so accuracy there's no sense in which
this high accuracy translates into like
a high degree of improvement
um so now we try to answer this question
like how is it possible that this do
system can be simultaneously so accurate
yet
um
ineffective I'm gonna post this
explanation based on the role of
environmental features right so we're
claimed that the graduation outcome of a
student is conditionally independent of
all measured individual information of
that student once we know students
environments all right and get into more
detail about this
so U.S schools in general and Wisconsin
in particular are very highly segregated
across school districts so when you look
at students who belong to the same
school all these students look much more
similar than what you would expect based
off random sampling of the Statewide
population
so from the perspective of on-time
graduation students in each School are
basically identical it's not that wrong
to think that each student like if a
school has a hundred students it's
really one student copied 100 times
all right
so once we know someone's school it
doesn't actually help us to know any
individual information about them like
what their disciplinary history is how
many days they were in school what their
test scores were in order to gain any
more information about what their
graduation outcomes
so this conditional Independence
statement is not something you can prove
regularly rigorously we can try to
disprove it particularly test some of
its major implications and see if they
hold or not and we'll see why this
explanation can try to simultaneously
explain the accuracy but ineffectiveness
of the system
so one corollary of this independent
statement is that if you predict
someone's graduation outcome just using
individual feature sorry just using
environmental features and you compare
the performance of that predictor to a
model that uses both environmental
features and individual features both of
these models will do roughly the same
right because like the in these
individual features and graduation
outcomes become uncorrelated once we
condition on graduate on environments
so we can test this and you know the
statement's not exactly true you do do
better if you include individual
features but you do not that much better
so you improved grad squared loss by
around 10 percent and here on the x-axis
I'm plotting like what is the marginal
Improvement in prediction you get from
including any one feature on top of an
environmental based predictor so we see
things like attendance rate are like the
most important but each one of these
things generally provides not a lot of
signal
uh above what we know already from the
environmental model
so try to explain how this
um dependent statement explains both the
accuracy and ineffectiveness of the
system
so graduation outcomes and environmental
factors are very highly correlated
so you can predict someone's probability
of graduation just by knowing their
environment
so if you plot the calibration curve so
these are models I train
um using the data that we have available
so one model uses all the available
features and one model just uses the
environmental features and if you plot
their calibration curves both of these
things look about the same right so
there are small gaps so you do get like
a 10 Improvement but it's really kind of
like if you plot the curves it's not
obvious that these things are all that
different you know
um great
um so this Independence is consistent
with high accuracy of who's graduating
from school who's uh
um and
it also tries it also explains why the
system is ineffective so I'm here I'm
going to plot two histograms of
graduation likelihoods for students in a
specific School
so this is when I came into this project
this is like what I thought schools
would look like so there's some x-axis
it goes from zero to one and here I'm
plotting like what is the individual
likelihood of graduation for students in
that school
um Michael gave a talk on this is like
Nature's probabilities like Nature's P
star and then so this school will say
the average is around 80 percent and I
imagine that most students would have
true likelihood around 80 percent
there's some higher performing students
there's some lower performing students
and the goal of prediction is to really
figure out who's in this like red area
right like who needs help so we can
intervene on them but in practice
schools look like this
so either everyone has a high graduation
rate or no one has a high graduation
right there's like basically no variance
in the within School District
um so I'd like to emphasize this is for
like a specific school like if you look
at like variants across the state
there's a lot of variants but all this
variance comes from the fact that
different schools do very differently
but once we look at each school students
look the same
okay
School services
this is the predictions for students in
a specific school oh so here is a
prediction yeah so these are pre
probably their graduation
based on the model that uses all the
available features yes so this is for
like a typical school so this is for a
school like picked but I'm going to try
to convince you as a typical so if it
was like a bad school with these yeah
this point Mass would be here
interesting yeah so this is based on all
pictures
uh no I'm saying like it really there's
not a lot of variance in this
distribution right like it's most that
two people on the left are probably
random noise so
so particular yeah so let me be more
clear about what I'm trying to say so
Independence means that all students in
a school have near identical likelihoods
of graduation so going back to this list
it's two students belong in the same
school this means I should basically
assign each student the same probability
of graduation not exactly of course but
like approximately
um this is like a by and large statement
um so any variation in scores with any
particular school is basically random
noise first counselors that look at
these scores they find that the scores
are like not don't really match up with
their personal interpretation of which
students need help
and due to this disconnect counselors
just realize the scores are
uninformative ignore them
right so scores that are ignored can't
have any impact
and why we see those systems ineffective
yeah Charlotte so in terms of the
intervention model are they is it okay
to like apply an intervention to an
entire school or is part of the problem
but like within each School these
counselors are looking to apply it to
the bottom like 10 or something and when
in reality it would be better to look at
the bottom sensors
yeah so you're getting to my office
um so yeah I'm talking about five
minutes all right
um great so looking back like taking a
step back like what does this mean about
policy and like the impact of early
Warning Systems more broadly so it's
exactly getting to Charlotte's question
so going back to the beginning of the
talk I mentioned that early Warning
Systems really are about targeting right
they're meant the the question they need
to answer is like who needs help right
they like a good early warning system
should give me a very accurate answer to
this question
then what we find is that there's you
know you can think about two allocation
strategies right you can either try to
intervene you know rank all students in
Wisconsin uh by assigning them
individual likelihoods of graduation
where I can simply rank students by this
school-based ranking
where I simply assign each student the
graduation rate in their school and then
I do this kind of course ranking based
off school graduation rates and what we
find is that due to this like
statistical pattern the individuals and
outcomes are independent conditional on
their environments both of these
sorority sortings are basically the same
right like the individual allocation is
like it's not exactly no better it's
like only marginally better than just
the school-based allocation so the
marginal value of prediction for this
problem is kind of near zero right it
doesn't actually answer the question of
who needs help better than just taking
an expel Excel spreadsheet and ranking
schools by graduation right and to kind
of give you a sense of how Stark this is
and how Dropout prevention is really not
bottleneck by prediction there's five
schools in Wisconsin that account for 10
of all dropouts right if we're really
trying to solve a targeting problem
there's very easy ways to answer this
question of like who needs help that
don't require any kind of sophisticated
prediction tools
um
so the question really should not be
like who needs help this is actually a
very easy question to answer
the question is like you know it's clear
who needs help like what should the
interventions be right like what how do
we actually change things and I guess
one thing I want to kind of clarify is
that this independent statement that I
made it's really just a statement about
observables right it says like this is
something that's from the perspective
observe data it's true it makes no
claims about what kinds of interventions
are more effective right it doesn't rule
out the fact that individual
interventions or School interventions
are any more or less likely right this
is really just about focusing on this
like targeting problem which is what the
prediction thing is trying to solve
great so you have some minutes for
questions
if you look at it maybe one way to look
at these particular stories this first
school that were 80 of the students are
attending the Cyrus it doesn't mean
anything right because it's not like if
I focused on those 80 20 I'm going to do
anything different yeah but for that
other school that you you actually did
show us where only three kids in the
school were third of Cyrus you can ask
whether for those schools does so so
this is not good you write that the main
answer should be this yeah
also prevent dropouts in favor parking
schools maybe these school scores are
effective there but if you have a school
where everyone has a 95 chance of
graduation there's only three students
that need help it's very likely the
counselor knows that even without your
scores even without your scores right it
doesn't tell you like my I'm not a
bottlenecked in this High performing
school that's a different question
whether they you think I'm saying what's
the marginal value of prediction right
like how much better can I Target
resources if I use the system versus if
I don't well
I know you're saying something different
you're saying that I don't need to in a
currency system developer because it
still come so it can actually
intuitively because the makeup of
students is such that this is a very
easy question I answer right like
there's basically either everyone sees
help or no one needs help no and if no
one needs help people where three kids
need help I need to identify those three
things
the last question no I have a question
about like resource allocation because
funding is my school board right School
District exam this test is across the
state so I'm wondering uh are you
suggesting this because like the state
will allocate funding for these I'm sure
five schools in certain school districts
right like how does that map to like
this mismatch right so where money is
allocated as a highly political question
but at the very least we should like
know exactly this like we should not you
know fool ourselves already this
question who needs help whether you do
something about it it's something that
others believe
okay thank you we'll take the rest of
the questions
okay the next talk is by